freunde wird erst nur drei verschiedene
youtuber gerichte die von diesen youtube
selbst kreiert wurden unter anderem abo
leds burgess für die müsst ihr euch ein
bisschen gedulden denn wir fangen an mit
montana blacks legendären nudelauflauf
zeigt euch wie ich meine
ihr erinnert euch vielleicht ich habe
den schon mal in der folge persönlicher
koch gemacht allerdings habe ich da
probiert ihn zu optimieren ich werde
jetzt das originalrezept sie haben alles
hier was wir brauchen wir können
loslegen als erstes schneide ich einfach
mal alles schnappen uns unsere paprika
wird heute wirklich eine sehr entspannte
nummer und ich werde dann am ende auch
den gewinner führen also das beste
youtuber gericht meiner empfindung nach
und sagen nur so viel bei vielen kommen
irgendwie auch so fertigprodukte und
irgendwie sind alle immer so unfassbar
überzeugt von ihren rezepten dass es
nicht wirklich auch reizt die alle mal
auszuprobieren
ich habe auch nicht mehr so die beste
erinnerung daran wieder montana berg
nudelauflauf geschmeckt hatte also ich
glaube er war relativ neues aber ich
habe den damals für ivan jo gemacht also
sind alles sachen die wirklich super
easy anzurichten sind falls ihr sie
ausprobieren wollt ich meine könnte
natürlich auch die original videos
gucken sind alle verlinkt weil er das
anschauen aber wird auf jeden fall eine
ganz entspannte nummer heute monte
schneidet seine zivilen einfach nur in
streifen und genauso werden wir es
machen durch jede zutat ist identisch
mit denen die monte verwendet hat bzw
natürlich bei den anderen gleichermaßen
und ich bin wirklich gespannt welches
der gerichte am besten sein wird das hat
auch jede menge roten zügen dann machen
wir das auch ist doch klar so ich setzte
schon mal wasser auf wenn die fusilli
werden anders als es hier auf der
packung angegeben wird zwei minuten vor
gebrochen nicht länger geben etwas öl in
die pfanne und darin braten wir gleich
das hackfleisch knusprig an wir lernen
auch später noch interessante moves mit
öl entdeckt habe ich ein bisschen
gelacht als wir uns vorbereitet haben
das geht sagt also hackfleisch rein wir
machen übrigens die halbe portion von
montes version also wie er macht hat
drei gerichte und wollen nicht so viel
superviel haben das sieht übrigens kraft
nach einem placement aus ist es aber
nicht sondern es ist halt einfach monte
hat einfach dieses gewürz in seinem
gesicht so die champignons schneidig
auch noch eben mundart montag auch
einfach so zack zack zack kreuz und quer
bisschen schmitz und dazu geben wir
jetzt unsere zwiebeln und champignons
ebenfalls paprika kommt auch dazu ebenso
etwas vom mais finde ich ganz alles
so ein bisschen salz ins wasser und
unsere nudeln konkurrent alex hat kaymer
auf zwei minuten dann gehen wir jetzt
unsere creme fraiche dazu das ist schon
außergewöhnlich auf jeden fall und jetzt
kommt ein halber liter wasser drauf
nehmt euch auf jeden fall eine große
pfanne wenn ihr das selbst nach macht
jetzt die wichtigste zutat
[Musik]
wunderbare spirelli alla mamma mischung
alexa wie viel zeit auf dem thema
ganz wichtig nudeln raus so werde das
ganze so aussieht können wir uns auch
schon daran machen und so einen auflauf
zu schichten so wir nehmen uns dann
jetzt eine schicht nudeln legen die
unten auf den boden indem wir unseren
edamer geben denen da oben drüber dann
zieht das schon so ein bisschen 50 haben
steht auf der packung und monte benutzt
200 gramm türlich aber muss wirklich
sagen also fühle ich sehr
gut drauf
erneut muss eins zu eins gleich das
ganze natürlich auch gesalzen und
gepfeffert wir machen die nächste
schicht nudeln schon eine spezielle
kreationen muss man echt sagen
eigentlich dann genau wie monte drücken
wir mit so einem pfannenwender schön
platz jetzt muss das ganze noch die
raffiniert werden mit käse wir haben wir
frischen most arena den wir in scheiben
schneiden dann rüber damit und jetzt
jede menge käse davon auf gar keinen
fall dran sparen sagt papa monte dann
kommt der ganze spaß 30 minuten
beziehungsweise bis oben schön braunes
in den backofen aber wirkt wo wäre man
mit 50 gramm käse hingekommen war nicht
weit ich freue mich die erste sache die
wir heute probieren werden ist endlich
fertig montana blacks legendärer
nudelauflauf eine halbe portion aber ich
glaube davon kann trotzdem eine ganze
familie essen ungefähr können wir mal ob
er knusprig geworden ist
klingt glaube ich ganz gut und ich werde
mir jetzt erst mal eine portion
rausholen
schon gut
und man sieht auf jeden fall die nudeln
sind wo man ordentliches stück größer
geworden also leute montana blacks
legendärer nudelauflauf das erste mal
dass sie ihn in der originalfassung esse
also erst auf jeden fall schön kasic
hier käse das ist eine champignon dabei
brauchen wir probieren
3,1 millionen aufrufen das rezept zu
diesen auflauf weiß man ja noch eine
rolle spielt beim und dennoch manchmal
so im monte universum überhaupt
auftaucht aber für mich so auf jeden
fall reagieren also kannst wirklich
krass kommt und was auch wirklich das
geschmacks beträgt ist die paprika also
die ist durch den ganzen auflauf
durchgezogen das hat er selbst
hinzugefügt also ist das auf jeden fall
sein eigenes gericht auch wenn seine
tüten kurzum es quasi und ich muss auch
sagen es ist nur richtig krank ist
gericht was du so schaufeln kannst die
nudeln sind cremig muss sagen das
gericht also viel nudeln sind relativ
weich haben sich vollgesogen mit dieser
creme fraiche gewürzmischung dazu noch
dieser käse der stellenweise sogar so
ein bisschen knusprig ist ist schon echt
gut das aber natürlich trotzdem sagen im
vergleich zu so einem geilen auflaufen
guten italienischen restaurant isst hat
er schon mich nicht ganz so gute karten
also ich weiß es noch nicht aber er ist
schon echt lecker und ich kann mir
vorstellen dass der heute unter unseren
drei gerichten echt gut abschneiden wird
ja und wir kommen jetzt zu den upgrade
burgess sie sollen besonders gefährlich
und süß kommen vertraut mir freunde die
appetit burgess mit tobi tüftel schießt
da kommt richtig gefährlich so richtig
süß ich habe bei diesem rezept mir
selbst überlegen müssen was macht
eigentlich den ganzen tag auf text wie
funktionieren diese bürger ich bin zum
schluss gekommen er sagt es sind fitness
server deshalb habe ich protein bansko
die sehen auch wirklich eins zu eins aus
wie die die er immer benutzt hier haben
wir hackfleisch glaube es sind so eine
art smash burger 400 gramm 100 gramm pro
partie kommen glaube ich gut hin so dann
wird es zeit die bands anzutasten
aktuell dpa die bands wie gesagt ich bin
mir sehr sicher dass das auch so protein
fitness band sind die erhard getrieben
in der pfanne verteilen wir auch noch
mal schön das öl gehen jetzt mittig eine
kugel hinein backpapier drauf und
drücken das ganze blatt mit einem top
wichtig dass das ganze den durchmesser
vom bahn hat
zwei schöne pettys gucken wir nach
unseren band sie kriegen langsam
bisschen trost dann wenden wir das ganze
auch schon
so leute jetzt wird es entscheidend so
wir klappen das ganze zu einfacher
cheeseburger brötchen raus sagt sagt
ritchies hier drin schmeckt der käse
noch mal schön an ich weiß nicht genau
wie weit das macht aber sehr käse auf
den bungies aufgeschmolzen ich mache das
jetzt einfach mit einem bunsenbrenner
guck mal das ist doch typisch wieder
sich dann so nach oben und dann sind wir
auch fertig guckt euch mal die schönen
röster um an das hier ist die unterseite
wir geben das ganze ihr seht perfekt
genau so groß wie unser bahn kommt
darauf mayonnaise
gefährlich ketchup auf fusion sagt dann
versuche gurken tomaten extra dünn rote
zwiebeln und wo im deckel drauf wenn das
mal nicht aussieht wie ein börse macht
jetzt auf dem zweiten und dann sehen wir
uns zum essen hier sind sie also die
jazz mit roten zwiebeln gewürzgurken
extra fein geschnitten alles david
ritchies wie schmeckt wo das am meisten
gehasste deutsche tik tok gericht ich
schon sehr gut aus muss ich sagen also
ich liebe auch smash berger tritt
schießt auf jeden fall eine ansage man
hat noch nie gesehen via poletti
gegessen hat nennt wir sind zum ersten
mal wie ein aktuell.de cheeseburger es
mit der möchte habe ich genau dass man
erwischt super weich protein beim
ausprobieren
wirklich sehr sehr saftig aber nicht
schmeckt nicht denn es fehlten auch
glaube ich habe so freunde dazu ist noch
eine folge georgio
angst ganz ehrlich spaß beiseite
diese bürger sind wirklich gut dreifache
zubereitung im prinzip hatten zunächst
burger der immer geil ist aber ich
verstehe den hype darum weil als ich das
erste mal smash bürger hinweg habe ich
auch so ich habe alle eingeleitet habe
es für alle gemacht einfach guy ritchies
reparieren weil die cremigkeit ist
glaube ich auf jeden fall einer der
favoriten das wurde aber auch echt gut
aber das schon recht stark die dritte
sache die wir ausgesucht haben es aber
auch stark das würde ich sagen damit
machen wir jetzt weiter und wir kommen
auch zum letzten mal zeit nämlich dem
dgb crunchpad
der wurde mir von euch vorgeschlagen auf
instagram deshalb habe ich ihn hier auch
noch mit reingenommen wir schnappen uns
einen portier legen einen schlüssel
drauf und schneiden daraus einen kleinen
tier so funktioniert das ganze nämlich
gleich und hat seinen großen stadt hier
seinen kleinen topf und dazwischen kommt
das ganze fing dann wird das so drauf
gefaltet wird er sein geschäft erstmal
den herd an ich habe kein einziges mal
gegessen in indianapolis bei takko weil
es gibt einige lustige dinge in dem
video von da gehen wir geben erst mal
oliven öl zum braten in die pfanne und
dann das macht folgen so salzen wir das
olivenöl
habe ich bisher auch noch nicht gesehen
aber wir wollen die authentische
experience dann müssen wir da hat da
gesagt es ist nicht so wichtig aber wir
machen es trotzdem unser hackfleisch zu
einer platte von herz so auf drei
viertel der hitze wir arbeiten auch hier
wieder mit 12 fertigprodukten nämlich
nach fertigen käse soße und fertigen
nachschuss wir machen das ganz original
wir haben jetzt ein bisschen die käse
soße auf hat jetzt auch temperatur
bekommt unsere riesen bulette braten
jetzt quasi einmal an und wirklich
wichtig ist das ganze heißt klaus repp
das wirklich alles alles alles kräftig
gebraten ist unschön kruste bekommt weil
das muss man ihnen lassen wirklich als
das am ende getestet wurde hat so
richtig so man hat so gehört dass ich
krank und das müssen wir erzielen nach
einer gewissen zeit wenn das ganze schön
braun karamellisiert ist klippen wir das
ganze daher hat mir nicht vertraut und
das weg gegangen aber du wolltest mich
fällen sehen aber nein etwas curry etwas
salz noch dran war sie als
gewürzmischung die haben so eine so eine
gewürzmischung so nicht fertige die
irgendwie immer benutzen zu können die
habe ich jetzt nicht gefunden aber mein
auch im video man soll einfach sonst
curry und salz benutzen jetzt geht es
eigentlich nur noch angst zusammenbauen
aber das machen wir genauso wie im video
hier unser knusprig gebraten hackfleisch
geben wir unten auf unseren portier dann
kommt jetzt unsere käse soße drauf das
krank ist halt wir haben käse sauce und
kirche darauf kommen jetzt für den crash
daher auch krank rap und sortiert so
hier oben drauf haben jetzt einmal creme
fraiche gemacht im video ist einmal
creme fraiche aber zufrieden wir haben
uns einfach für kim fresh entschieden
weil es war ein bisschen
missverständlich danach kommt jetzt klar
kam ohne die ist natürlich selbstgemacht
einfach aus tomate avocado und zwiebeln
für dann etwas eisbergsalat wenn man
will kann man jetzt noch haller pennies
drauf packen so und zum schluss das
ganze ist jetzt gut verteilt ich habe es
ein bisschen zusammengedrückt und jetzt
können wir beginnen mit der falttechnik
wir wollten zuerst eine ecke rein und
falten wir eine hinterher an die nächste
dabei halten wir das ganze schön fest
dass es jetzt so genau kopfüber quasi so
das werden wir nämlich genau jetzt
machen also unseren kranz rap kopfüber
in die pfanne legen und so packt er
jetzt quasi zusammen
ja das war es schon so sieht das ganze
aus wenn es fertig ist schön die tiger
von unten von oben auch schön braun so
sieht's aus es wird zeit
bedarfsplans rap hoffen wir haben das
vor allem mit dem kranich gut
hinbekommen beim retten ist auf jeden
fall probieren sie
auf jeden fall das ist gut gefüllt die
nachos haben in quant schon vorher
verloren das dachte ich mir aber auch
nicht nur die ligen hat auf dieser käse
so so ich finde man schmeckt auch ein
stück weit dass da viel industrie drin
ist weißt du das muss man sagen der
textur unterschied so von dem knusprigen
im weichen und saftigen inneren ist
schon sehr geil bin mir auch sicher dass
das ein geiles format ist und wann
schreibt da kannst du bestimmt auf seine
koch ebene so ein bisschen höhe treibt
ist das übelste ich würde aber fast
sagen ich es jetzt mal ein bisschen dann
komme ich zu meinem ranking von den drei
gerichten kommen wir zur bewertung
welches ist das geilste gericht von
denen die wir heute gekocht haben wir
fangen von unten an und der zweite platz
ist doppelt belegt von kranj raps mit
dem legendären nudelauflauf weil die
machen beide sachen sehr gut aber auf
der anderen seite ist das einfach so ein
industrieller geschmack so der von den
fertigen komponenten da reinkommen so
wie es dasteht teilen sich die beiden
platz zwei und auch nummer eins sind die
fdp wies die sehr gefährlich da
hergekommen sind und einfach süß kam mit
der folge jo nich sagt wirklich die sind
super natürlich auch nicht besonders
gesund auch in operetten wie manchmal
als fitness bürger bezeichnet aber es
war lustig heute props auf jeden fall an
alle die sich dann eigenes rezept
überlegt haben ich finde das ist gar
nicht mal so leicht sich etwas eigenes
zu überlegen deshalb auch wenn ich nicht
alles krass abgefeiert haben respekt
dafür wir sehen uns mal nächsten video
wieder bis dahin und macht's gut